my name is Alana new house and I'm the
editor-in chief of tablet this is a talk
for the network state conference tablet
is a Jewish magazine about the world
broken ism is a theory that what really
divides us now is not left or right in
the US democrat or republican liberal or
conservative but actually our
relationship too and feelings about the
health of our institutions I think a
parallel media is being made right now
the concept of broken ism is that the
fundamental debate we're having is
around the health of our current
institutions and on the one side there
are people who I call status quoist
these are people who are trying to
protect and preserve our current
institutions um many of whom are some of
my closest friends um I absolutely
understand these impulses on the other
side are uh people who I call broken
nests and these are people people who
not only do they believe that many of
the institutions in society have become
so decayed and so not only irrelevant
but actively undermining of people's
lives that they have become
dangerous and that it is dangerous to
continue to portray them as healthy to
people because we are not allowing
people to prepare for a different future
so so Brokenness uh at least the ones
that I know love uh love to think of
like uh literally physical Place
metaphors so the the metaphor that they
use is is this building is really
decrepit and you are telling your
kids that they should be inside it and
they should live there and that building
is going to fall down on them you are
literally putting them in danger by not
only fixing those institutions but
legitimating them for people some
including some of the people that are
closest to you I might say that a
perfect world is one in which people
have IRL politics internet principles
and religious values build something
that someone needs whether it ends up
working or not you will learn something
and it will make you build something
really great next thank you so so much
thank
you